on retrouve l'envoyer spécial de France
24 Jonathan Wolf qui est en direct avec
nous depuis la ville de nicolaïve
bonjour jonaton alors à combien de
kilomètres de personnes sont aujourd'hui
les forces ukrainiennes
en tout cas les combats sont
effectivement très intenses nous avons
pu l'observer avec les artilleurs que
nous avons accompagné sur le front et
puis il faut également mentionner que
l'évacuation
opérée par les Russes évacuation de
réarsson les Ukrainiens parlent plutôt
eux de déportation n'est pas prise ici
du tout comme un signe que les Russes
comptent abandonner ouraient abandonner
rapidement la ville au contraire ce
qu'on entend plutôt ici c'est que les
Russes ont passé ces dernières semaines
à fortifier leurs défenses et avant
Herson il y aura des objectifs
stratégiques ou les combats seront
forcément très intenses il y a notamment
ce barrage hydroélectrique de carrovecka
que les Ukrainiens les Russes
s'accusent mutuellement de vouloir
détruire au risque d'inonder la région
et puis un dernier mot sur mikolaïf où
je me trouve qui est à 50 km à vol
d'oiseau à l'ouest de rerson cette ville
est une ville de garnison il y a
beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de force
ukrainiennes positionnées autour de la
ville et elle n'est donc pas épargnée
par par les combats quotidiennement des
missiles frappent le centre-ville et la
nuit dernière encore des missiles S300
des missiles russes ont frappé le cœur
de la ville le cœur de nicolaïf